et je trouve ça inhumain j'ai passé des
super examens j'avais 20 sur 20 on m'a
dit non vous êtes une personnalité
publique vous êtes un personnage public
avant d'être un être humain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
soit de foot mais c'est fou
et sur TF1 il y en a plus et là ça
continue sur BeIn Sport c'est improbable
sur Twitter c'est un truc doux
égalisation à la 99e minute TF1 lancé
quatre mariages pour une lune de miel je
suis en larmes on est vraiment pas un
pays de foot oh le moment de légende sur
TF1 le match se joue encore alors qu'on
est devant le Camping Paradis TF1 qui
arrête de diffuser alors que le but est
refusé de ptdr les tarés des gens font
la fête en France en pensant qu'on a
égalisé vous avez du sang sur les ventes
c'est incroyable c'est une erreur
historique en fait c'était TF1 qui a
acheté ah bon avec bein qui diffuse mais
ils ont les mâles de l'équipe de France
et grande fête populaire des millions de
je regarde des troubles moyen de faire
ça mais c'est du jamais vu quoi ah non
ils veulent pas que les gens décrochent
qui balancent partout on aimerait qu'il
fasse une interview ou deux à la fin du
match ça éviterait des cas comme ça
parce que c'est vraiment ça c'est
exceptionnel pour coup un but qui est
remis en jeu après la fin c'est déjà
arrivé
en tant que homme de télé comment vous
expliquez ça l'oseille est plus
importante que la diffusion il y a la
pub qui va arriver l'interview de d'un
joueur qui ont rien à [ __ ] ils sont
des balancer vite la pub interview tu
vois ce que je t'explique en fait à la
fin des matchs
la courbe d'audience ça chute en une
minute
vertigineux ça veut dire que tu passes
de 10 millions de téléspectateurs à 2
millions tu perds 8 millions de
personnes donc plus il lance la vie la
pub vite le premier spot oui cher
puisque les gens restent encore devant
la pub enfin ils essaient de les
accrocher donc ils essaient d'envoyer le
plus vite possible donc là forcément ils
sont partis trop vite et Benjamin
connaissant
[Musique]
sur l'humilité des coups de béquilles
les deux influenceurs propriétaires du
chien et soupçonnés d'acte de cruauté
envers leur animal risque jusqu'à 5 ans
de prison 50000 euros d'amende mais le
couple ni tout en bloc et accuse
directement la lanceuse d'alerte jeudi
dernier vous allez au domicile d'Europe
et Roca donc French rap Queen les
influenceurs accusés d'avoir maltraité
leur chien c'est ça c'est ça vous y
allez pourquoi c'est une soirée faut
savoir que j'ai reçu un message sur mon
compte snapchat où il me disait que
salut ça fait longtemps qu'on s'est pas
vu on organise une soirée ce soir du
coup je suis allée là-bas et bah c'était
pas du tout une soirée déjà c'était pas
du tout une soirée c'était une soirée
photo donc ils aiment bien contacter des
gens pour des photos d'accord et ce sont
c'était vos amis si vous allez connu il
y a deux ans suite à ça j'ai arrêté de
leur parler car il y a une affaire de
soupçon de viol donc de drogues et de
viol donc suite à ça j'ai arrêté de leur
parler j'étais naïf j'avais 16 ans donc
je suis retourné je me suis dit
peut-être qu'ils ont changé peut-être
que c'était qu'une polémique comme voilà
et je suis allée
vous entrez dans l'horloge ils habitent
à Argenteuil et là vous voyez le chien
il était dans quel état
il était recroquevillé il respirait fort
il pleurait oui il faut savoir il
pleurait quand son maître-europe il
venait il se faisait pipi dessus il
avait peur donc vous avez été inquiétude
directement parce que je sais que ce
n'est pas la première fois parce que
déjà on peut voir déjà les bosses on
peut voir les
commentaires les hématomes elle avait
aussi une plaie énorme comme ça sur le
corps une ici disque apparemment
c'est pas eux leur version ils disent
que un chiot comme ça en une soirée on
ne peut pas lui faire ça on voit déjà
que les boss ça fait quand même un peu
longtemps
il vous accuse vous en fait non oui oui
m'accuse clairement moi mais là il faut
savoir qu'ils sont placés en garde à vue
déjà ils sont passés en garde à vue
même dans le passé vous n'avez jamais
tapé sur le chien
il faut savoir que le chien c'est la
première fois de ma vie que je l'ai vu
cela celui-là Texas c'était la première
fois de ma vie que je l'ai vu parce que
ça fait deux ans que je n'ai pas vu
cette personne là pourquoi il vous
accuse
le buzz écoutez c'est sous le temps la
même chose et ces gens-là il méritent la
prison ferme c'est pas la prison avec
des travaux d'intérêt général c'est
immonde de voir ça mais la justice en ce
moment même elle ne sert à rien bon là
heureusement qu'ils sont placés en garde
à vue d'ailleurs j'ai une confrontation
avec eux à 9h du matin demain donc voilà
en tout cas on nous tiendrez au courant
de la suite
et sur W9 dans les Marseillais en
Thaïlande que les téléspectateurs
découvrent Aurélie Preston
encore traumatisé par ces événements la
jeune femme tente alors de mettre fin à
ses jours dans la nuit du 2 octobre
dernier à sa sortie de l'hôpital aurélie
ne pèse plus qu'une trentaine de kilos
et poste ce message sur les réseaux
sociaux nous vivons tous ces épreuves de
la vie de façon complètement différente
je vous raconterai un jour mon histoire
le livre démarre comme ça vous dites je
n'ai le 17 juin 1792 à Saint-Denis il
est 9h30 ma vie commence dans l'hôpital
le plus sordide du 93 mon sang est sale
héroïne craque cheat que ma mère
Fabienne a consommé pendant sa grossesse
bienvenue au monde c'est la vérité c'est
la vérité
on va dire que c'est des fils de se
construire comme ça et que justement
dans ce livre j'ai pu m'exprimer enfin
et poser des mots sur mes mots parce que
c'était très difficile pour moi de
pouvoir parler de certaines choses ma
vie c'est un film tous les jours c'est
une série Netflix je me réveille le
matin je me dis ok aujourd'hui je dois
gérer quoi la tentative de suicide de ma
mère là elle allait la chercher dans un
parc public le jour de la Toussaint de
la trouve en cellule dégrisement trois
tentatives de suicide en l'espace de
deux semaines vous dites que votre mère
vendait du crack se prostituer et
vendait également des montres volées
c'est la vérité parce que
malheureusement ma mère a beaucoup
souffert dans sa vie et à subit
l'inceste et ma grand-mère n'a pas
divorcé de cet homme qui lui a fait
subir ça donc ben elle est partie vivre
en fait à Saint-Denis à la croisée
malheureusement bah une mauvaise
personne mon père et je comprends mieux
aujourd'hui et je l'explique très bien
justement dans l'ouvrage que je n'ai pas
croisé mon père pour certaines raisons
et notamment le fait que c'est lui qui a
injecté ma mère pendant qu'il était
enceinte de moi donc voilà c'est un
départ dans la vie qui est assez
difficile et c'est difficile au
quotidien de se relever malheureusement
pour moi j'ai subi avant la télé le
harcèlement déjà et c'est en ça que
j'aimerais dire quand même à toutes les
personnes qui sont à l'école et qui sont
en cours que en fait pour moi c'est loin
d'être des victimes parce que se lever
tous les matins et avoir le courage
d'aller affronter des gens qui harcèlent
au quotidien et aujourd'hui avec
justement le smartphone les réseaux
sociaux les médias etc c'est un 360
infernal et le harcèlement il est
permanent avant on pouvait couper juste
les smartphones
vous gagnez très bien votre vie dans la
télé la télé
en tant que nouveau dans les Marseillais
on gagne 3000 € par quoi
3000 euros le tournage entier en tant
que nouveau c'est combien de temps le
tournage c'était presque deux mois j'ai
gagné sur mon deuxième tournage 12000
euros et comme vous le savez tous je
pense j'ai fait un procès pour faire
respecter mes droits d'artistes et j'ai
gagné d'accord donc on va dire que
c'était pas non plus incroyable ça vous
plaisait la téléréalité
ce qui me plaisait c'était le rêve en
fait qu'on m'a vendu c'était quoi le
rêve qu'on vous a vendu de pouvoir enfin
faire de la musique et de faire ce que
j'aime et pouvoir vraiment gagner ma vie
en prenant du plaisir quand 99 autres
pour cent de la vie c'est de la torture
et devoir gérer sa famille et je trouve
ça très péjoratif de dire tentative
parce qu'en fait quand on en est là on a
plus envie de vivre et on n'est pas là
pour tenter en fait on fait tout pour y
arriver moi
j'avais vraiment rien à perdre quand
j'ai fait tout ça et tout était très
bien pensé je vous le dis j'avais mes
dernières volonté sur mon ordinateur
j'avais les codes de bancaire j'avais
écrit les messages à mes amis pour leur
dire de s'occuper de ma grand-mère de
faire si ça ça et c'était pas un c'est
pas une tentative quand on n'en peut
plus de vivre on n'en peut plus de vivre
parce que justement tous les jours on
porte énormément de choses et les gens
le savent pas et je suis loin d'être une
bimbo téléréalité ou autre et loin
d'être la vitrine qu'on voit sur
Instagram qui rigole et qui essaye de
positiver de donner de la goût de vibe
parce que en fait aujourd'hui j'ai
compris que si j'avais que touché le
ciel et que j'étais revenue ici c'est
pour aider des gens comme moi qui sont
appelés tous les jours de victimes alors
qu'ils sont survivants vous avez publié
une photo choc sur insta c'était quand
cette photo c'est un mois d'août au mois
d'août posez combien de kilos
et je trouve ça inhumain
réinsérer dans la vie moi je voulais
vendre mes réseaux sociaux
essayer de faire de l'immobilier je suis
parti en Suisse j'ai passé des super
examens j'avais 20 sur 20 on m'a dit non
vous êtes une personnalité publique vous
pouvez pas faire travailler dans les
assurances
avis et quand vous demandez à Google à
un des référencement que vous payez des
avocats pour cent vous dites quoi non
vous êtes un personnage public vous êtes
un personnage public avant d'être un
être humain
et c'est quoi en fait ma vie c'est de
passer toute ma vie pour une personne
qui a eu aussi une poupée gonflable sur
un plateau télé avec sa photo dessus
c'est ça c'est ça Aurélie dans la vie de
tous les jours non Aurélie c'est une
battante c'est une fille qui se lève
tous les jours et que c'est qui sait
pourquoi et là et qu'elle en veut et
justement quand j'ai voulu arrêter de
vivre c'est parce que le 1 % qui m'a
toujours raccroché à la vie quand on m'a
dit tu as fait de la télé tu signeras
jamais en maison de disque et ben j'ai
fait le 1 % et j'ai signé en maison de
disquet j'ai monté mon propre label et
j'ai toujours été comme ça et bah là le
1% il y a un mois et demi il existait
plus simplement
vous regrettez d'avoir fait de la télé
bien sûr je regrette
quoi dans la vie Sébastien moi je suis
responsable en menuiserie dans
l'événementiel quoi donc je sais que
vous avez économisé beaucoup d'argent
pour pas mal de déplacements et vous
vouliez payer votre mariage avec cette
montre en fait exactement donc en fait
au moment que je l'ai acheté j'ai tout
je me suis dit dans ma tête en fait
c'est comme un placement à la banque
c'est ça qui voulait en fait clairement
mais vous avez raison vous décidez donc
de poster une annonce sur leboncoin
écoutez bien cette histoire
donc là un homme vous envoie un message
et échange son numéro de téléphone avec
vous exactement vous êtes appelés oui
oui il m'a demandé mon téléphone il m'a
appelé c'est ce que j'ai dit en fait le
courant au téléphone est très bien passé
en fait moi de base je voulais faire la
vente chez moi et du coup il me dit
qu'au final il est obligé d'annuler
parce que il a pas trop le temps il a
repris il est un peu pris au travail
tout ça on décale le rendez-vous en fait
au dimanche et moi j'ai dit au final que
ça m'arrangeait car en fait le dimanche
c'était le baptême de mon neveu d'accord
donc on a fait la entre guillemets la
vente parce que au final il y a pas eu
de vente mais la vente en fait quasi
devant la salle à va mettre de la salle
donc vous quittez l'événement juste pour
la vente vous vous rendez à la vente
donc avec votre Père qui est avec nous
exactement donc par la suite il vérifie
quand même que ça soit bien authentique
qui vérifie tous les numéros comme
combat en fait elle était en feuille et
tout seul vous êtes tout seul je
pourrais voir juste à boite parce que
vous savez en fait il y a un numéro
derrière la boîte pour vérifier d'accord
et il la prend il regarde il dit bon bah
très bien on va faire j'ai cherché
l'argent ma voiture et il a pas le temps
de dire ça qui part en courant il s'en
va avec la boîte vous réagissez comment
le réflexe c'est je cours ah oui et je
dis à mon père il se barre avec et là
vous arrivez à l'attraper par la capuche
je l'attrape par la capuche ils
retournent il met un coup de poing donc
le réflexe je le pousse par terre
d'accord et du coup entre-temps le
complice parce qu'il y avait un complice
voilà il y avait un complice qui était
peut-être on va dire 100 m devant donc
là il y a une deuxième personne qui
arrive voilà et du coup donc j'ai juste
le temps de me relever et là donc je
reçois un coup de batte de baseball en
pleine tête donc ça c'est l'autre
l'autre Contis entre temps la personne
m'a quand même mis bah plusieurs coups
de poing au visage donc en fait je
reçois le coup de battes en pleine tête
ceux qui m'a mis le coup de batte ça
évite je l'ai pas vu vu que lui il a
toujours été loin devant
et lui je le reconnaîtrai pas parce que
j'ai pas enfin j'ai des petites images
mais vous voyez c'est flou vraiment ce
que je veux dire c'est que même dans les
petits villages c'est il y a de
l'insécurité donc des fois j'entends des
ministres dire c'est un sentiment
d'insécurité mais concrètement non enfin
c'est une réalité la preuve demain je
vais me faire opérer du nez parce qu'on
m'a fera cassé à coup de baseball quoi
mais j'aurais jamais pensé voilà comme
vous avez dit c'était combien 2000
habitants la commune c'est vraiment
enfin c'est et la police dit aussi ne
mettez pas de fausse du coup dans Paris
bien sûr parce qu'ils y connaissent rien
et vous tapotant
vous avez une bestiole qui
ce qui est un vrai problème de rat à
Paris et dans la région et voilà est-ce
que est-ce que je me fais une idée à
Paris particulièrement il faut bien
avoir en tête qu'il y a 2 millions de
Parisiens il y a 6 millions de bras
population estimée et en fait à Paris
depuis un certain nombre d'années
maintenant on voit on voit les rats
justement arriver en surface massivement
en surface et là c'est problématique ces
problématique parce que les races sont
propagateur de maladies c'est ça c'est
dangereux tout simplement ça donne aussi
une idée de de l'état d'un seul
d'insallebrité chronique de la ville
parce qu'en fait le problème c'est pas
tant qu'il y a des rats qui sont au
sous-sol ou qui est quelques rats qui de
temps en temps viennent en surface le
problème c'est quand vous avez des rats
qui massivement viennent en surface et
ça veut dire qu'on est on a atteint un
stade de crasse un stade de saleté un
stade d'insalubrité qui est inédit et
qu'on voit d'ailleurs dans aucune ville
au monde il faut nettoyer cette ville il
faut notoriété Paris et la seule
concernée accessoirement vous regardez
les autres villes alentours
le problème il n'existe pas vous
regardez les grandes villes françaises
qui sont aussi des métropoles qui sont
aussi des villes qui à Lyon on n'a pas
ce problème nulle part vous l'avez dit
Paris c'est dans l'esprit de beaucoup
c'est la plus belle ville du monde
aujourd'hui c'est la poubelle ville du
monde Paris bravo bravo
concrètement qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
nettoyer plus main dans la main avec les
éboueurs est-ce qu'il faut sensibiliser
les gens est-ce qu'il faut mettre plus
de poubelles la première des choses à
faire et on le voit dans d'autres villes
de France qui l'ont fait et qui n'ont
pas du tout ces problèmes d'insalubrité
chronique dans leur ville c'est et là je
vais lâcher un vrai gros mot pour en
tout cas pour la ville de Paris
peut-être certains d'entre vous mais
c'est faire appel au privé le privé
c'est très bien nettoyer des villes il y
a des villes il y avait il y avait pas
prêt ça veut dire quoi
on peut pas tout dire vas-y molo pierre
[Musique]
le journaliste Hugo Clément vient aussi
de sortir avec son nouveau média en
ligne va qui time longue enquête sur
pierre vaqueta et vos méthodes dans
cette enquête plusieurs témoignages vous
accusent sur le tournage de Nina Ricci
moi j'ai vu une chouette harpon mourir
on a fait le tournage ce qui vient à peu
près 3 jours pas les retours la chouette
n'a pas mangé ces animaux
qui vivent chez nous sont apprivoisées
dressés pour les tournages de films et
sont extrêmement familiers il se trouve
qu'une partie de ces animaux sont des
amis c'est le cas de cet aigle sont des
animaux que l'on nous confie que l'on
nous donne comme mais chez nous parce
qu'ils ont des problèmes c'est que cet
aigle par exemple a passé sa vie dans
plusieurs parcs et tous les parcs dans
lesquels ils se trouvaient il est né en
captivité ont eu des problèmes il est
très agressif qu'il a été mal élevé
d'accord est-ce que un animal que vous
sortez
dès sa naissance de des parents c'est
une erreur souvent l'animal après se
prendre pour un être humain et un
comportant avec vous comme il aurait
avec ses confrères c'est qu'on génère
quand son bébé ils sont très mignons
mais arrivé à l'âge adulte il se dit
qu'est-ce que tu fais sur mon territoire
et vous agresse venez depuis 5 minutes
sur ma main il m'a flingué un coup de
crâne un coup de bec sur le le cuir
chevelu en fait qui n'est plus chevelu
il m'a donné un coup de un coup d'elle
avec le coude qui est très dur il peut
vous ouvrir l'arcade sur la le visage on
ne le voit pas et on le voit sur la
vidéo il m'attrape ma main et là je me
dis il faut faire quelque chose
œil pour œil PEC pour bec je lui mets
une gifle alors c'est oiseau après je
suis allé m'asseoir on ne va pas l'image
est sorti de son contexte les réseaux
sociaux c'est le tribunal nord-coréen il
y a aussi cette histoire de de singe il
regardait
une singe Mago c'était vraiment une
singe qui était vraiment mignonne et
bien dressée et un jour il a vraiment
perdu son calme et il a tabassé un coup
de poing en plein visage tout le monde
hurlait on le supplie et d'arrêter et
quand il a enfin fini elle était elle
était défigurée elle était en sang il
lui avait vraiment éclaté le visage quoi
j'ai pris des photos le jour qui ont
suivi des photos voilà de son visage
complètement
rempli d'hématome de ses yeux qui avait
des cocards donc la chouette est mort ça
on est d'accord la chouette est morte on
Nina Ricci si vous me permettez de
répondre
c'est un super
avec le monsieur qui me dénonce c'est
extravagant cet homme a fait un cheminer
de loups et une chouette un Roumanie
pour le tournage et je leur ai dit voilà
vous devez arrêterez deux fois le matin
et le soir le matin et le soir du
deuxième jour du voyage et vous
nourrirez la chouette ce monsieur
extrêmement prêché pour rentrer le
résultat c'est qu'il ne s'est pas arrêté
une fois pour nourrir la chouette et
quand elle est arrivée elle était très
faible et cette chouette est morte et ce
monsieur a quitté mon entreprise mon
activité voilà la réalité c'est
extravagant que ce soit lui qui dénonce
cette chouette alors que c'est lui qui
l'a pas nourri je vous écoute non mais
le coca du singe c'est la diffamation le
cocard du singe donc il s'est fait le
coca tout seul je peux m'expliquer allez
il y a trois animaux qui viennent d'être
évoqués pour lesquels j'ai mené des
actions et j'ai les ai recueillis
effectivement un jour il a attaqué les
soigneurs les soigneurs et la personne
qui me dénonce je sais qui c'est la
bosse pas se cacher c'est notre
secrétaire qui s'appelle Catherine
Bréart et je peux vous dire que je lui
ai dit madame je vous descends d'aller
avec ce singe parce que il vous épouille
et puis tout d'un coup il va vous
regarder il va vous provoquer c'est la
vie les singes entre eux on dirait des
lois sociales très complexes singe je
vous accuse je connais pas le singe la
chouette je vous accuse pas je connais
pas je regarde juste ça quand vous lui
mettez c'est pas une jeep c'est une
patate vous lui mettez une droite et
vous dites alors et celle-là tu l'as vu
ça là merde alors c'est incroyable ça
c'est pas une manière d'élever ça voilà
on me demande de parler je pars si c'est
un aigle qui a été élevé par des hommes
et qu'on peut pas rééduquer etc pourquoi
vous l'avez pris il la laisse pas de le
dresser de le remettre comme ça
il faut vous dire plus personne moi je
préfère qu'il soit tout seul qui a
prendre des droites comme ça attacher
j'ai 4 secondes là évidemment que ça
allait extrêmement violent mais c'est
une histoire que vous auriez battu et ce
serait
évanoui est-ce que c'est vrai en fait
tout est diffamations oui non non bien
sûr mais là le le l'ourson est un animal
qui n'a pas du tout
été brutalisé jamais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]